foreign
who is this you tell me
you tell me
I don't think so
popcorn
uh-huh I
well I'm getting ready to watch a video
really what I'll do some scary movie
uh-huh
I don't know
what comes to mind
um Halloween
no the one with the guy in the white
mask who walks around and stalks
babysitters
what's yours
um Nightmare on Elm Street
yeah Freddy Krueger Freddy
wow the first one was with the rest
sucked so yeah
why you want to ask me out on a date
no
why do you want to know my name
what did you say
it's not what you said
what do you think what
look I gotta go
now I don't think so don't hang up on me
hey
hello
[Music]
is that you Randy
and what movie is this from I spit on
your garage
lose the outfit as Sydney sees it she'll
flip
oh you want to play Psycho Killer
can I be the helpless victim
okay let's see no please don't kill me
Mr Ghostface I want to be in the sequel
cut Casper that's rap
Joy
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
corn syrup same stuff they use for pigs
blood and carry
[Music]
surprise Sydney
oh
what's the matter Sydney you look like
you've seen a ghost
you
we already played that game remember
you lost
games
you die you get it right you die
crazy both of you
three for the term psychotic I'll never
get away with this
tell that to Cotton weary
I wouldn't believe how easy he was to
frame
watch a few movies take a few notes
it was fun
why
how did you kill my mother why
yeah that's too I think she wants a
motive
I don't really believe in Moto suit I
mean did Norman Bates have a motive no
did they ever really decide why Hannibal
Lecter liked to eat people don't think
so
you see it's a lot scarier when there's
no motive Sid
you did your mom a favor said that woman
was a bag flashed her
all over town like she was Sharon Stone
or something yeah I would put it out of
her misery because let's face it Sydney
your mother was no Sharon Stone
hmm
is that motive enough for you
here it comes
[Music]
[Applause]
tomorrow
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
why are you even here Randy
you ever believed
Italy you no matter how hard you
try you'll never be the hero and you'll
never ever wait sorry hey man
dead boy
oh yeah well let's redirect the moment
Mr I'm so original huh
can I help you
sorry sorry
where's your Innovation huh why copycat
two High School loser ass Stu
was a ass wet rag and Billy Loomis
Billy Loomis what the Jesus what a
wrath looking homo repressed mama's boy
why not set your goals higher huh you
want to be one of the big boys huh
Manson Bundy OJ
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
okay outside everyone stay together and
try to remain calm
it's not mine
interior Jennifer's house living room
night the script page
The Bodyguard stabbed to death the five
stand trapped he's rewriting the movie
The Killer race outside
like the facts between
everybody outside outside
the killer prepares to Grant Mercy to
only one of them
and to Lena do we Gail the killer will
give Mercy too
Stay Together
[Music]
whoever smells
oh
yeah
Jennifer
[Music]
reason I'm here is to help you so that
my death will not be in vain that my
life's work will help save some other
poor soul from getting mutilated
Keeler does come back and he's for real
there are a few things that you got to
remember is this simply another sequel
well if it is same rules apply but
here's a critical thing if you find
yourself dealing with an unexpected
backstory and a preponderance of
exposition then the secret rules do not
apply because you are not dealing with a
sequel you are dealing with the
Crafter
trilogy church that's right it's a
rarity in the horror field but but it
does exist and it is a force to be
reckoned with because true trilogies are
all about going back to the beginning
and discovering something that wasn't
true from the get-go Godfather Jedi all
revealed something that we thought was
true that wasn't true so if it is a
Trilogy you are dealing with
here are some super Trilogy rules one
you got a killer who's going to be
superhuman stabbing him won't work
shooting him won't work basically in the
third one you gotta cryogenically freeze
his head decapitate him or blow him up
number two anyone including the main
character can die this means you said
I'm sorry it's the Final Chapter it
could be Reservoir Dogs by the
time this thing is through number three
the past will come back to bite you in
the ass whatever you think you know
about the past forget it the past is not
at rest any sins you think were
committed in the past are about to break
out and destroy you
so in closing let me say
good luck Godspeed
and for some of you
I'll see you soon
because the rules say some of you ain't
gonna make it
I didn't not if you're watching this
tape
let's do it
I'm sorry sorry
Roman's dead what the Killer's here
listen to me
I did not felt that pig Milton to get a
leading role just to die here with
second
is like you two
over here
you guys should get no it's crazy to
still be here
[Music]
[Applause]
Jennifer up here
to pick up Roman and Angelina too we'll
be safer we stick together won't we of
course why
what's going on oh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh you
what you follow directions well Sydney
now now with a final Act see that metal
detector
use it
all over Sydney everywhere
everywhere the other leg too
show it to me
[Music]
throw it in the pool
now come inside Sydney no way
how do I know they're not dead already
they're they're right inside wait
wait look for yourself
now that we're all here the party can
begin
that's it where is he I don't know
he's right there
oh
think again
it's your turn to scream
where is he I said who is it
let's call the cops
I dare you to open the door no Sherry
don't no don't I'm scared
anyone that we know Lisa Bailey Wayne or
the hopeful long shot Channing Tatum
foreign
there's nobody out here
what does it say
it says I'm not outside I'm right beside
you
[Music]
[Applause]
kidding me
what
that was so stupid pure horsesh
at the death of horror right here in
front of us I jumped scared me a
Facebook killer you're kidding me right
I guess now it would be Twitter that
make more sense a bunch of articulate
teens sit around and deconstruct horror
movies until Ghostface kills them one by
one it's been done to death the whole
self-aware post-modern meta sick of
working 99-6 already
I like the stab movies they're scarier
it's not aliens or zombies or little
Asian ghost girls there's something real
about a guy with a knife who just
snaps
it could really happen
I can't do it these sequels don't know
when to stop they just keep recycling
the same even the opening scene
there's always some random girl who gets
to call it undoubtedly ends up getting
her killed it's also predictable there's
no element of surprise you can see
everything coming
oh
did that surprise you
why because you talk too much
now shut the up and watch the movie
[Music]
oh my God I love it I've seen it five
times and it still gets me every time
you're kidding
get it
is this Trevor do I sound like a forever
to you to you think of me as your
as your time movie you got a fun part so
don't blow it what movie same one
marnie's in only her part got cut way
back
blonde with the big tits we'll have some
fun with you before you die I have a 4.0
GPA and 135 IQ what did you do
with Marnie she
that's not funny this isn't a comedy
it's a horror film people live people
die and you better start running
[Music]
thank you
good night
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
sucks to be a cop in a movie I see Bruce
Willis
not all cops die in movies
no but if your last day before
retirement you do
if you're rookie just find that your
wife is pregnant you do
horsepower is better looking than you
you do and by the way
you know and I'll take the next
perimeter I'll be right back
I know this one you're not supposed to
say that are you yeah new decade new
rules you know these days you might come
back find me dead I scouged out tongue
sticking out could go either way I gotta
learn this yeah I'll take this one
hey Haas
be careful I'm always careful
Dead Man Walking
[Music]
thank you
Perkins was there a window open on your
last perimeter check
Perkins come in over
here
damn it
you should have seen the look on your
face rookie
[Music]
[Applause]
oh I'm afraid someone's gotta die
now no no no Amber I'm coming
ing
[Laughter]
systems are
always
all sisters disarm
[Music]
systems
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh-huh
bonus question Tara
stop do you think I made it inside your
house before you could re-arm
laughs
[Music]
[Applause]
bubbles
Sheriff Hicks hello Sheriff Judy
who is this I think you know I'm a fan
of scary movies and knives what's your
favorite scary movie
I prefer animated films and musicals why
are you doing this I'll tell you all
about it I'm going to turn myself in
I think that's a great idea we'll sit
down at the station and I'll tell you
all about the two people I've killed
you've only killed one person by the
time I see you I'll have gutted your
baby boy
[Music]
this is Cherokee I need units to
converge on my house ASAP
can't get him on the phone can you he
must be busy how do I know you're
anywhere near him ever seen the movie
Psycho
[Music]
please
don't hurt my boy oh why not he's a good
kid is he now he never heard anyone
that's not enough please I'll do
anything you're not gonna make it in
time Sheriff Judy
[Music]
I found it
huh
get out of here
come on hurry up
the head
what you have to shoot him in the head
they always come back Dewey who gives
the
I do it
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
on Earth
[Music]